- ♪ Toute seule, je crame ♪
♪ C'est le drame dans ma tête ♪
- Fatima Zhara, aussi appelée
La Zarra, vous faites sensation
sur le Web, un malheur
en France. Et vous avez juste
un premier album. Ça va vite
et bien. Comment vous voyez ça?
FATIMA ZAHRA HAFDI, auteure-
compositeure-interprète
- Ça va très vite là-bas,
en France. C'est comme,
tu peux... T'as s s abonnés
sur Instagram, tu te fais
signer pour un single, tu...
Ça "buzz" un jour, tu sais...
Après, mais moi, j'avais
vraimenenene idée précise.
Et je pense que c'était un vent
de fraîcheur pour eux aussi.
Puis, ils ont vu que j'étais...
Moi, je travaille jour et nuit,
et ils ont vu que j'avais faim.
Puis, ils ont fait : "On est
sur elle", tu sais. Mais c'est
vraiment, ils ont misé sur moi
comme j'ai misé sur eux.
♪ Elle était belle
loin de la jungle ♪
- Vous êtes née à Montréal,
mais votre histoire ressemble
un peu à un conte de fées. Parce
qu'en 2016, vous rencontrez
le producteur à Montréal,
Benny Adam's. Tous les deux,
vous êtes un peu ivres et
vous chantez la chanson de
Céline Dion "Pour que tu m'aimes
encore". Et là, ça a cliqué.
Comment ça s'est passé?
- J'ai chanté... Après, je suis
pas mal sûre que j'ai pas très
bien chanté. Mais lui, c'est
une personne qui est capab
de se projeter. C'est
un visionnaire, puis il m'a
dit : "Bien, viens au studio
demain". Et de là,
on a commencé à travailler
sur plusieurs chansons.
Et on a fait "Printemps blanc",
qui a été ma... ma première
chanson qui a sorti en France,
avec un rappeur qui s'appelle
Niro. Ete e e e e là que j'ai
compris qu'il y avait peut-être
une possibilité pour moi d'avoir
une carrière dans la chanson.
♪ Mon coeur blanc ♪
♪ Souvenirs d'un
printemps blanc ♪
- On ne connaît à peu près
rien de vous. Vous êtes assez
mystérieuse. Autodidacte,
vous ns s s s s de formation,
donc, en chant. Vous l'avez
développé comment, ce talent-là?
- YouTube. Ha! ha! ha!
En écoutchchchchchanteuses
préférées. Vraiment, je les ai
étudiées. Que ce soit Barbra
Streisand ou Barbara, Piaf...
Aznavour, Frank Sinatra.
J'ai vraiment appris à chanter
en écoutant leurs chansons.
J'ai appris à écrire aussi en
écoutant leurs chansons. Mais...
C'est aussi simple que ça.
- Et semble-t-il que vous avez
pratiqué beaucoup dans un salon
de coiffure où vous avez
travaillé. C'est vrai ça?
(rire)
- Oui, en fait, c'est que
je mettais justement ma playlist
avec mes chansons d'antan.
Et ça travaillait l'oreille.
Donc, à force d'écouter
la journée, c'est sûr que on
commence à comprendre la formul.
♪ On s'est dit des choses
ininininininin ♪
- Dès la première note
qu'on entend de vous,
on est essoufflés.
Elle vient d'où cette voix-là
de... ce don-là... Est-ce que
vous considérez que c'est
un don? Que c'est à force de
travailler? C'est...
- Les deux, je pense. Je sais
que... si vous demandez à
certains de mes amis, ça fait
10 ans, ils vont dire :
"Mais, elle chantait comme
une casserole."
(rire)
Et c'est vrai! Je ne sais pas si
c'est... j'ai percé quelque
chose dans ma voix et je l'ai
travaillé en fait. Et, euh...
Oue e e e e e e e c'est un don,
mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
travail. C'est... j'essaie de...
... de m'enseigner à moi-même
comment atteindre certaines
notes et... voilà! Mais je pense
que j'ai encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire et je sais que
je ne suis pas au plus haut de
mon potentiel, vocalement.
♪ De mes bras ♪
♪ Tu t'en iras ♪
- Votre musique est un mélange
d'Édith Piaf, il y a du hip-hop
là-dedans, de la musique arabe
aussi. Pourquoi vous mélangez
tout ça? Est-ce que ça vient
de vos racines familiales?
- J'ai grandi avec toutes ces...
ces influences musicales.
Ma mère écoutait beauco
de musique arabe à la maison.
Je ne vais jamais nier
mes racines parce que... b b b s
nous ont quand même élevés avec
les valeurs de... de leur pays.
Mais je suis née et
j'ai grandi au Québec,
donc c'est mes racines aussi.
Je me vois québécois
♪ Vous n'avez jamais
entendu la voix ♪
♪ De ceux qui n'ont
jamais gagné ♪
- Mais ça fait quand même
un beau mélange : l'Afrique
du Nord où sont nés vos parents,
et puis le Québec finalement!- ,
c'est... c'est toujours joli.
(rire)
♪ Laissez-le-moi ♪
Remplir ma vie ♪
♪ Juste un peu ♪
- Je sais que à première...
À premiè p p p p p p p p p peu
un mélange bizarre parce qu'on
se dit : comment est-ce qu'on
peut mélanger une valse et
rajouter un autre style.
Ça s'est vraiment fait
naturellement. Après,
je ne pourrais pas l'expliquer.
C'est... ça c'est...
C'était inné, puis moi
et Benny, on a réussi à...
Bien, à rapporter ce nouveau
genre, si je pourrais dire.
- Fatima Zahra, La Zarra,
merci beaucoup.
- Merci à
♪ Oui, je dis souvent ♪
Ça va ♪
♪ Même si c'est le bordel
autour de moi ♪
♪ Je ne suis pase e e e e e e e